So what today I want to tell you are basically
two things about the Russia probe and the
left.
I hinted at talking about this in the first
segment.
First of all, I believe that the left is slowly
converging on agreement about the Trump Russia
probe and some of the really toxic disagreements
are starting to fade away.
And that's a really, really good thing.
The second thing I want to mention is that
the left had damn well better figure out how
not to be divided on the Russia probe in a
way that is toxic and destructive because
it's going to crush us in 2020 to the extent
that the internal leftwing disagreements remain
as prominent on this issue of the Russia investigation.
A really big deal has been made over the last
several weeks since the bar letter about the
Russia probe came out about who was right,
who was wrong, who needs to apologize, who's
exonerated, and who can go on a victory tour
around the United States or around Twitter
as it has actually been in reality.
I expected the right to do this, but even
the left has been engaged with it.
People demanding apologies, a of people claiming
exonerations.
I don't want to minimize how bad it has been
because it has been really, really bad, but
what I want to point out is that I've seen
slowly but surely the good faith left, which
is most of it.
I want to be clear, converge on a pretty coherent
and unified story on the Russia probe.
I'm going to give you one example.
Okay.
Glenn Greenwald is a journalist.
He's a prominent Russia skeptic.
He's been very critical of many elements of
coverage of the Russia probe and he seems
to have in just two weeks changed his tune
on the issue of whether there is any evidence
of collusion from the Russia investigation.
Take a look at these clips.
First one's from democracy.
Now.
Second one is from the majority report.
Would Sam Cedar pay really close attention
to what he says here two weeks ago on democracy
now, right when the bar letter came out, look
at what Greg Glenn Greenwald said about evidence.
The media got this story wrong.
They obsessed on this for three years and
all this kind.
There was no evidence for it.
It was just a conspiracy is conspiracy theory.
Rachel Maddow, the most influential liberal
TV host in the country every single night.
Misled millions of liberal.
That is really, really clear.
No evidence, no evidence.
And uh, by the way though, two weeks go by
and we start to realize, oh, you know, the
bar letter is a public relations documented
the report.
Uh, the, the, the bar letter is totally politicized.
No evidence is probably a little over, a little
bit overboard compared to what we actually
know given that we haven't even seen the molar
report yet.
And Sam Cedar Interviewed Glenn Greenwald
late last week on the majority report and
look at Glenn Greenwald.
Very different answer about no evidence.
Now I noticed like when you talk about the,
the Mueller investigation, you're not saying
there's no evidence that he found no evidence
anymore.
I'll eat because all we know from the Bar,
uh, assessment is that to the extent that
he found any evidence and maybe he didn't
find any, uh, but he could have also found
some.
Right.
But just not enough for an indictment.
You agree with that?
So the, so we're not going to know her and
told them all our parties release what exactly?
Riding mower.
Sad.
Right.
But so, but I do think it's important to note
the following in general, prosecutors have
a very narrow mandate.
Right?
Okay.
So that's very clearly not what he said on
democracy now on democracy now, he was shouting
there was never any evidence.
And there's no evidence here when he's confronted
about it by Sam, he goes into explanations
of prosecutorial mandates and thresholds of
evidence required for indictment.
And then here's another moment from later
in the same interview with Sam
precise.
I mean, nobody would say no evidence, right?
Like the Trump tower meeting is evidence,
right?
So then the question is, is it like compelling
evidence as a convincing?
So yeah.
Yeah, I agree with you.
I agree with you.
Like there were people who are getting out
in front of their skis on this stuff and you
may be right about what established means
in that.
We're not going to know until we see the,
uh, the report.
And I hope we do end up seeing that.
So Glenn now agrees with Sam, or it sort of
sounds like he agrees with Sam about this
issue of evidence, but he was saying something
very different two weeks ago and he was saying
it very loudly on democracy.
Now.
He went from angrily proclaiming that there's
no evidence and there never was just sort
of equivocating and saying, well, what do
we mean by evidence?
Evidence that reaches which which standard,
which has a very significant change.
Now I want to be clear, I'm not criticizing
Glenn Greenwald here.
I'm praising Glenn Greenwald.
We shouldn't shame Glenn Greenwald because
he went from saying no evidence to, well,
there's evidence.
What is the evidence mean?
What threshold does the evidence reach and
let's wait and see what Mueller says.
He was very emotional in the democracy.
Now interview, we've all been emotional about
this, but he revised his point of view, which
is great and I believe that at this point
in time the left is basically 90% in agreement
on the Russia probe.
Let me put up on the screen what I think almost
the entire left agrees with and what we disagree
on.
The left most of the agrees that Trump is
likely criminal when it comes to financial
crimes and corruption, that Trump was never
likely to be indicted for personally colluding
with Russia.
That the Mueller probe was legal, that the
Mueller probe should have taken place.
That corporate media sensationalize the story
that William Barr has an undeniable history
of covering up presidential crimes.
That the bar letter is a political document,
not a summary of the probe, that the full
molar report must be released.
That Trump colluded was never a good 2018
or 2020 strategy for Democrats and that waiting
around for Donald Trump to be removed by either
impeachment or 25th amendment removal is a
terrible strategy for Democrats.
I can boil down the left's disagreements on
Russia, not hyperbolically, not on tone and
language, but on the facts to what was the
right amount of coverage of the probe as it
was going on.
There are disagreements about that and what
was the correct context within which the probe
should have been covered.
I think 90% of the left is converging on that
set of beliefs, agreements and disagreements
and that's a good thing and everybody who
is participating in getting United on what
didn't, didn't happen is helping the left
per 2020 and if we can't get past this, it's
not going to be good in the next election.
Agree with me.
Disagree.
Let me know.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pack, the
David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com